you were very dead set on like every
single day
i wanted to focus on doing the basics
extremely well and that's what i really
focused on how can people master the
basics and in your perspective what are
the the basics for a successful contract
recruiter that you keep top of mind yeah
so
like you said right it's with everybody
trying to be different to everyone else
out in the market there's there's so
much noise out there and it is so easy
to get lost in the noise and if you're
trying to focus on 20 different things
that can improve you as a as a recruiter
or as a person
you're not really going to put you know
100 effort into all of those 20 things
for me
i went back to
write what was i doing in in lockdown
how did i build my desk to where it was
so the basics for me are always just
picking up the phone and building a
relationship over over the phone right
in a mad digital world at the moment
where it's so much easier to send a text
an email or a linkedin message i've got
rid of like socials because i just can't
deal with the noise and clients and
candidates won't really look at linkedin
because they're getting hounded by
recruiters on there okay so picking up
the phone and just building
relationships is like a basic skill set
that i think that you need
organization i was not organized at all
for about two years really it's kind of
chaotic but i quite like being chaotic a
little bit right but for me i always had
like a main focus but i would never
really plan a day properly
i've really started to do that in the
last year which is where i think again i
made the stepping stone to get to my
weekly gp so i will plan my day
not to the t but i will i would set six
important tasks that i need to achieve
the next day in order for me to achieve
my goal by the end of the week so
organization
being on the phone and just following
through just deliver on what you promise
to clients and candidates
nobody likes being let down if you let
the client down or the candidate down
ultimately you're going to let yourself
down
and that's where you're going to find
yourself in a funk if you've tried
absolutely everything that you can to
deliver on something that you've said
that you're going to deliver to then you
can finish work knowing that you've
given everything those three areas are
so basic and people glaze over them so
much
[Music]